in deutschland hat gewählt was kommt
nach angela merkel ganz herzlich
willkommen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer zum internationalen spät
shoppen wir wollen in den nächsten 45
minuten den blick mal ein bisschen
weiter wir wollen mal ins ausland
schauen schauen wie das ausland auf
diese bundestagswahl geguckt hat und
welche erwartungen welche hoffnung
vielleicht auch welche sorgen es gibt
was eine neue regierung angeht und dafür
habe ich spannende gäste hier bei mir
die ich jetzt begrüßen möchte zuerst die
französische journalistin cécile calla
lange zeit haben sie gearbeitet zum
beispiel für immer und jetzt sind sie
freie journalistin und autorin schön
dass sie da sind links an meiner seite
tatjana firowa korrespondentin für
interfax die russische presse agentur
schön dass sie da sind
freier journalist vor allem für die los
angeles times und ralph sina lange
korrespondent in afrika in washington
und vor allem in den letzten jahren der
europa korrespondent im ard studio in
brüssel schön dass sie alle hier sind
bevor wir aber wirklich einsteigen
wollen wir einmal ganz kurz weil sie
lange keine zahlen gesehen haben auf die
neuste hochrechnung schauen damit wir
wissen wo wir gerade stehen
nach dieser hochrechnung kommt die union
auf 24,5 prozent die spd auf
25,9 prozent die fdp liegt bei 10,6 die
fdp bei 11,7 die linke bei fünf und die
grünen bei
14,1 dass also die neuesten zahlen das
bedeutet auch wir wissen am ende jetzt
überhaupt noch gar nicht wer in zukunft
deutschland regieren wird in welcher
koalition schon gar nicht was wir auf
jeden fall wissen das ist 16 jahre
angela merkel diese ära ist jetzt zu
ende was bedeutet das was haben 16 jahre
angela merkel bedeutet ich würde zuerst
sie fragen
wie haben sich in 16 jahren angela
merkel wie hat sich das transatlantische
verhältnis verändert
angela merkel wirklich ein bollwerk für
die usa in europa sie war wechseln ganz
treue begeisterte partner für die
amerikaner sie war mehrere gewinne sie
hat eine rede vor dem kongress gehalten
zugejubelt vor allem in den usa ist die
decke in die höhe gestiegen nach der
flüchtlingskrise diese es gibt viele
amerikaner die die lieben diese art von
liberale unterstützung und merkel hat
wirklich alle register gezogen für die
diese art von amerikaner mit dieser
flüchtlingskrise die märkte haben auch
institutionen vietnamesische leute und
so anzunehmen profil amerikaner war
merkt das nonplusultra und dann auch in
diese trump seit wann merken natürlich
auch für viele amerikaner die
gegner waren auch merkel war so eine art
hoffnung für die zukunft und ich glaube
diese gerüchte dieses brillen gibt dass
barack obama ist extra hierhergekommen
und wenn wir 20 67 um diese überreden
noch vier jahren weiter zu machen dass
das glaube ich schon dass das stimmt ja
aber merkel hat so lange gebraucht um 20
17 zu entscheiden vier jahren ich habe
immer gesagt merke wer jemanden die
wirklich gerne aussteigen würde würden
die leute das nicht gewollt ein bisschen
früher aus geplant aber wer weiß aber
jetzt ist sie hat es geschafft jetzt ist
sie durch und serien ein riesiger ruf in
den usa
erarbeitet und verdient und vor allem
ich fand sie mir persönlich wie sie
diese persönliche draht zu amerika
gehabt hat nie reden manchmal würde sie
was zu erzählen wie sie hat gesagt sie
können usa erst sehen denn wenn sie in
rente ging und sie haben immer gesagt
die für einige staaten von amerika hat
das ganze komplette phase immer gesagt
und man spürte dass man sportlich
wirklich ein großer freund von der merck
und ich glaube die nächste die die
beiden regierung hofft nur dass die
nächste deutsche regierung auch so ein 1
berge so eine unterstützung die werte
der usa
frau karla angela merkel hat mehrere
französische präsidenten kommen und
gehen sehen sagt chirac hat sie begrüßt
mit handkuss das verhältnis dann bei den
nächsten war so ein bisschen abgekühlte
jetzt emanuel makro wie würden sie das
verhältnis von den beiden beschreiben
also in der tat sie hat ja mit hier
französische präsidenten gearbeitet also
immer nur in micron ist der vierte
präsident insofern hat sich ein bisschen
erfahrungen auch mit französischer
politik und sie bleibt so als bild der
stabilität so in frankreich also man hat
damals das sie gewählt wurde 2005 hatte
man ein bisschen den befürchtungen ob
sie wirklich tatsächlich so viel machen
würde ob sie wirklich eine überzeugen
überzeugt ist von den deutsch
französischen tandems ob sie genauso
viel für europa machen wird und dann mit
der zeit hat man ja gemerkt dass man
trotzdem zum kompromiss kommt und dass
da die deutsch französische achse
funktioniert auch wenn sie nicht mehr zu
dieser kriegsgeneration
gehörte im vergleich zu gera oder zum
beispiel und mit emanuele micro hat sie
gut gearbeitet und vor allem
am ende als sie sich zusammen geeinigt
haben für über diesen wiederaufbau von
der die möglichkeit von gemeinsame
anleihe
ermöglichte und das war für frankreich
wirklich ein sehr sehr wichtiger schritt
und sehr wichtiger kompromiss
nachdem man den eindruck hatte dass man
sehr viele vorschläge gemacht hat für
europa sie erinnern sie sich bei der
letzten bundestagswahl 2017 und sehr
lang wurde
sie richtig bombardiert makro mit vielen
vorschläge für reformen in europa und
sie war natürlich konnte erst mal gar
nicht antworten weil weil es gerade
bundestagswahl gab dann gab's lange
verhandlungen fünf monaten behandlung
und dann war hat sie auch nicht so
richtig so klar sich positioniert bei
den vorschlägen zu werden war auch ein
bisschen
enttäuschung zu spüren in paris aber wie
gesagt also was sie jetzt erreicht haben
in dem letzten jahr machte
zumindest diese palast jetzt zufrieden
und man war natürlich sehr nervös jetzt
in der perspektive der bundestagwahl man
man kennt ja man kannte ja sehr gut den
deutschen partner man wusste was möglich
war welcher spielraum und jetzt ist ja
alles noch sehr offen also offen ja
genau das stimmt ralph sina das bild das
man zu angela merkel hat was das
außenpolitische handeln angeht das ist
ja so ein bisschen widersprüche es gibt
die einen die sagen sie ist die große
krisenmanagerin gewesen in den letzten
jahren die die europa auch
vorangetrieben hat und gleichzeitig gibt
es stimmen die sagen sie hat die großen
krisen ausgesetzt ausgesessen und hat am
ende
kompromisse gefunden die aber vor allem
kompromisse sind was ist ihr bild ich
glaube sie ist eine der besten
krisenmanagerin der neuzeit und ich
glaube dass die eu vielleicht schon fast
in den abgrund gefallen wäre wenn es
angela merkel nicht gegeben hätte die eu
hatte extrem viele krisen in den letzten
jahren ist gab die euro-krise es gab die
griechenlandkrise die flüchtlingskrise
und vor allen dingen die korona krise
und gerade weil angela merkel keine
vision von europa hatte wie makro gerade
weil sie so defensiv gerade weil sie so
gegen vergemeinschaftung von schulden
war gegen eurobonds weil die 180 grad
wende die sie gemacht hat eine sensation
und die tatsache dass sie so defensiv
gestartet ist hatte sie glaubwürdig
gemacht im lager der sparsam bei den
niederländern bei den dänen bei den
österreichern die kein corona
wiederaufbau von wollten gerade weil sie
da so glaubwürdig war haben die ihren
schwenk mitgemacht hätte sie die großen
visionen von vornherein gab wie makro
und im figaro und le mont und alles
gewonnen das alles ausgebreitet hätte
sie diese chance verspielt gerade weil
sie so defensiver und rückte sie mochte
und auch kurz nicht gegen sie irgendwie
konnte konnte sie diese leute mitnehmen
und sogar ein viktor orban dazu bringen
den selbsternannten liberalen demokraten
dem krone wieder auf fonds zuzustimmen
dem haushalt zuzustimmen und nicht zu
blockieren
und das war eine sensationelle leistung
man muss fairerweise sagen
das in brüssel an die kästchen
olaf scholz war mithin beteiligt olaf
scholz als finanzminister hat mit bruno
lemaire dem französischen finanzminister
nächtelang hier in berlin gesessen im
deutschen finanzministerium und hat
überlegt wie kommen wir von den euro bei
uns weg aber trotzdem zu einem
rettungspaket und es war mit scholz der
mittelmeer das ausgedacht hat merkel hat
es dann als kanzlerin durchgesetzt aber
es war im grunde genommen ein bisschen
tandem situation zwischen den beiden das
ist vielleicht auch mal historisch ganz
wichtig aber merkel ist für mich die
frau scheitert der euro scheitert europa
die griechen bleiben im euro gegen
schäuble gegen ihren ehemaligen
finanzminister lässt sich dann doch die
griechen dann gelassen wirklich
wegmarken gesetzt und ich glaube ohne
sie wäre die eu so ein bisschen
natürlich binnenmarkt aber auch ein
chaos klub und so war es binnenmarkt und
merkel was sie hatte auch lange gezögert
für griechenland also sie hat lange
gewartet bis sie jetzt letztendlich
diesen diese entscheidung getroffen hat
der grieche behalten richtig sie hat
druck gemacht sie ist findet schon mit
papandreou 2010 an als sie eine
volksabstimmung machen wollte denn wenn
du das machst dann wird hier nichts mehr
mit griechenland helfen da sagen wir
ganz klar und sie hat was unter druck
gesetzt aber letztlich hat sie vor allen
dingen schäuble wieder standen mit der
unterstützung von juncker und seinem
kabinettschef selber muss man sagen die
auch gesagt haben das geht gar nicht
dass die griechen geben um himmels
willen und in der tat zurückblicken
während die griechen damals aus dem euro
raus und dann der exit gekommen es wäre
ein desaster gewesen insofern war diese
konfrontation die merkel auch mit
schäuble durchgezogen hat sie hat ihn ja
in gewisser weise dieser wert war
richtig rückblickend betrachtet und für
mich war sie die figur auf dem auf dem
brüsseler parkett und makro konnte diese
visionäre rolle nur spielen weil er
merkel die realistischen an seiner seite
hatte sehr spannend natürlich auch immer
auch innenpolitisch dann spannende
konstellationen die es da gegeben hat
ich möchte einmal noch den blick weiten
richtung osten frau vier so war ich
glaube wenn man hier in dieser runde
schaut das verhältnis dass russland zu
deutschland hatte es könnte man
vielleicht einfach sagen das
komplizierteste gewesen
wladimir putin und angela merkel haben
ein interessantes verhältnis zueinander
kühl und trotzdem ja gleichzeitig immer
auch so dass es da weiterhin gespräche
gegeben hat dass sie sich in irgendeiner
weise auch respektiert haben finden sie
dass angela merkel mit wladimir putin
richtig umgegangen ist in den letzten
jahren
ich glaube ich glaube auf jeden fall ist
dann geber merkel für die russische
politik eine person die man richtig
respektiert und auch nicht nur für die
politik die ja ist auch in der
bevölkerung sehr respektiert vor allem
weil sie natürlich eine frau ist weil
sie schon so lange an der macht ist ich
glaube die russische bürgerinnen und
bürger schätzen auch da sie
über keine wahnsinnig teure häuser
verfügt oder im autos teure autos fährt
das ist auch glaube ich ganz wichtig und
diese beziehung
ist mir einer seite ein bisschen schwer
zu sagen weil ich nie in den
journalisten pool von wladimir putin
gearbeitet haben wir deswegen weiß ich
nicht genau wie diese beziehungen
zwischen den beiden gewesen sind aber
2005 als sie zu macht gekommen ist da
bin ich auch habe ich auch mit meinem
journalistisches praktikum angefangen in
moskau das war auch so meine zeit so zu
sagen ich bin auch dann gekommen als er
gern angela merkel ist natürlich sehr
ganz leicht gemacht mich nicht
ja und und diese zeit war
für mich gar nicht geprägt dass vor
allem die regierungskonsultationen
regelmäßig stattfanden zwischen russland
und deutschland
an denen natürlich bei der frau merkel
und herr putin beteiligt waren und auch
so die fiel mäßig waren die beziehungen
viel lockerer als vielleicht davor weil
es gab ganz viele touristischen reisen
ganz viele viel austausch miteinander
und natürlich nach dem jahr 2014 das
stichwort ukraine
ist hat sich die situation vollkommen
geändert und
jetzt ist man da wo man ist und das ist
ja jetzt schon deutlich kühler als
ausgegeben das muss man jetzt sagen also
in den letzten jahren habe ich das
gefühl gehabt wahrscheinlich stimmen mir
alle zu das war ein sehr kaltes
verhältnis wenn auch weiterhin natürlich
gespräche immer geführt worden sind sie
sich mal gefragt ob die blumen die
wladimir putin ihr jetzt am ende
überreichte blumen sind das respekt oder
das eigentlich bin ich froh dass sie weg
ist
ich persönlich glaube dass das doch die
blumen das respekt sind weil ich glaube
und das hat er auch gesagt dass er sehr
respektiert ich meine sie hat immerhin
nord stream 2 gegen den willen anderer
europäer ja bis zum schluss verteidigt
gegen polen gegen die baltischen staaten
und das muss man ja sehen dass sie
russisches gas letztlich befürwortet hat
und das ich finde die szene mit dem hund
wohin wissen dass sie diese diese hunde
angst hat da sein dass ich labrador oder
eine mischung aus irgendwelchen
kampfkandidat haben auf jeden fall ein
sehr großer hohen werte um sowohl den
raum hinein kommt genau und ihr doll und
er damit einfach deutlich zeigt wer ist
hier der chef und ich weiß genau wo
deine ängste sind hochinteressant ja ist
das denn aus amerikaner aus
amerikanischer sicht so dass man da auch
ein bisschen mit argwohn geschaut hat
wie gut am ende doch immer weiter der
gesprächsfaden zwischen deutschland und
russland war nein ich glaube das war gut
und wichtig dass er merkel ein dialog
mit ihm hatte und beide muss ich konnte
und vor allem merkel was ist die
konsequenz aus der nord stream zwei weil
sich sehr konsequent mit den sanktionen
und die friedensverhandlungen den globus
und so hat sie sehr gut gemacht und das
ist irgendwie der wunsch der amerikaner
dass die deutschen ein führungsrolle
hier übernehmen kann und diese regionale
probleme die märkte wirklich in asien
die hände alles sofort zu tun und obama
hat diese bunte bild gemacht und mit
china jetzt sieht man dass die spannung
in der werbe- und für washington ist es
schön und gut wenn ein starkes
deutschland hier eine führungsrolle
übernehmen kann ich weiß dass wollte
führung in deutschland geht nicht aber
das wohnen das war auch nicht ordinär
karner das wohnen die poren das wohnen
viele leute dass deutschland führen und
mehr merkel hat sehr gute führen gezeigt
in der russlands sachen in der in der
cream in der krise die wertekompass war
alles verstehe und von nord stream zeit
zb
südamerika ja sehr kritisch beinahe
beiden die konnte sie überhaupt nichts
mehr erreichen genau das ist kritisch
weil ukraine wirkt dadurch
probleme und die osteuropäer wollen das
nicht und diese diese milliarden an gas
die nach moskau schließt das ist
stabilisieren von moskau das
unterminiert die ganze sanktionen und
und die grünen in tegel in berlin die
wollen auch keinen zweifel das ist
überflüssig und das
verursacht spannungen in der eu
frankreich für auto gegen ja sagt jeder
hat seine blinde punkte oder aber die
amerikaner aber trotzdem keine
sanktionen dann gegen den zwei letztlich
machten aus respekt vor deutschland das
fand ich auch noch mal interessant das
war ja lange in der diskussion aber dann
also beim doch gesagt dass dann doch
nicht weil deutschland letztlich so
wichtig war um entschiedener ist super
wichtig und merkel blockt deutschland
als kunde der maschine jetzt gibt es
aber dieses nicht wohin er will damit
sagen wollte in dem verhältnis zu
russland aber das könnte man ja auch
sagen zu dem verhältnis zu china ist
dass man registriert zwar dass merkel
manchmal schon klar sache und vor allem
wenn es um den menschheits reichte geht
aber das jedoch sehr bereit ist sehr gut
zu kooperieren wenn es um die
wirtschaftsinteressen deutschland geht
also einen blick auf china tatsächlich
genau entwickelt also aber auch russland
und china natürlich wo sie sehr oft
gereist ist und und da wünscht man sich
auch
aus französischer perspektive aber auch
aus glaube ich anderen von anderen
nachbarn dass sie ihm das ist nicht nur
dabei bleibt bei einer diplomatie diese
fiel die industriellen interessen
bedient ersparen sie haben dass gerade
so ein bisschen gestriffen es gibt ja
diese neuen militärischen absprachen
bündnisse jetzt zum beispiel
großbritannien australien und usa
das verärgert frankreich europa spielt
offensichtlich gar keine rolle hier
entstehen neue bündnisse also das ist
ist das nicht auch ein moment von
schwäche jetzt an dieser stelle zu sehen
angela merkel und deutschland haben
nicht mehr die macht hier jetzt vorne
mit zu reden absolute und ich meine auch
die situation in afghanistan also das
vielzitierte beispiel des flughafens von
kabul wo er nun die nicht in der lage
war irgendwie noch zu handeln ohne
stützung der amerikaner noch mal ganz
toll nicht gemacht wo das defizit liegt
daran hat auch angela merkel nichts
geändert und in der tat muss europa da
zusammenarbeiten ist der völlige irrsinn
dass man beim betanken von flugzeugen in
kompatible systeme hat das kein
munitions austausch möglich ist et
cetera pp dass wir 27 verschiedene
waffensysteme entwickeln und viel mehr
geld als russland in die rüstung
investieren aber trotzdem militärischen
stecher sind also diese defizite sind
sicherlich eine herausforderung für den
nachfolger von angela merkel dass das
ganze hier und ich glaube afghanistan
waren um ein ganz großes ausrufezeichen
so geht es nicht weiter da muss die eu
auf jeden fall handlungsfähiger werden
ich finde das ist genau der punkt an dem
man jetzt sagen kann wo stehen wir denn
jetzt auch nach 16 jahren angela merkel
welche fange ich vielleicht mal mit
frankreich an sie haben das gute
verhältnis beschrieben aber welche
offenen baustellen sind jetzt da was
muss aus französischer sicht jetzt ganz
schnell passieren
ja sie haben das jetzt benannt was
müssen wir machen im bereich
verteidigung der werden die franzosen
sehr stark plädieren vor allem nach
dieser
nach dieser geschichte mit mit
australien großbritannien und
und und den usa was als schwere diplomat
seine schwere diplomatische krise
ausgelöst hat und das wird auch jetzt
sehr laut gedacht was jetzt die zukunft
der nato sein sollte oder wie welche
welche rolle sie einnehmen sollte aber
es gibt auch die frage des
stabilitätspakt die die franzosen und
andere länder in europa wünschen sich an
der reform was wird die nächste
bundesregierung darauf antworten dann
bleibt natürlich die frage des
klimawandel weiter sehr präsent und
und wie dass jemand sich eben
positionieren wird gegenüber das
treffliche beziehungen also dass es da
werden auch da wird man ja sehr sehr
stark auch für den jetzt schon gegenüber
den usa das ist ja interessant ist wird
stabilitätspakt wenn ich das kurz
einfügen darauf aus russischer
perspektive das wird die hammer nummer
für den merkel nachfolger denn bruno
lemaire ich darf ich noch mal ins feld
führen der französische finanzminister
hat auf dem letzten treffen in slowenien
jetzt gesagt dass man auf freunde diese
ganzen stabilitätsregeln das nimmt doch
keiner mehr ans nun also das ist ein 60
prozent des wirtschafts aufkommens als
schulden haben dürfen deutschland hat ja
schon 71 frankreich hat 119 und ganz zu
schweigen von griechenland die über 200
prozent haben und italien die 160 haben
also bruno lemaire sagt komm lass uns da
lockerer werden und realistischer und
das wird jetzt spannend wie reagieren
darauf ein bundeskanzler laschet oder
ein bundeskanzler scholz wie gehen die
damit umgehen sie in den konflikt mit
frankreich
in den konflikt mit dem club
méditerranée oder schwenken sie ein auf
diese linie lasst uns lockerer mit der
schuldenpolitik und umgehen und den
stabilitätspakt aufweichen das wird
glaube ich eine der dass hier der erste
lackmustest in brüssel werden wie
positioniert man sich da und ich glaube
da wird es spannend wer wird der nächste
finanzminister wird dass ein herr
lindner oder wird das eine habe da
könnte es sein in brüssel auch noch mal
unterschiedliche akzentsetzungen geben
frau 4 sowie sieht man eigentlich diese
neuen bündnisse die hier gerade
angesprochen worden sind dieses projekt
orkus in russland ich glaube offiziell
geäußert hat sich russland dazu nicht zu
diesem militärischen abkommen die also
sozusagen jenseits der nato stattfinden
nein noch nicht ich glaube auch noch
nicht aber ich habe heute kurzen
statement von der sprecherin des
russischen außenministeriums gesehen und
es ging so in der richtung dass wie sie
auch schon am anfang eigentlich in ihre
frage in wie erwähnt haben dass
in russland sieht man das so dass man
dem europäischen union sozusagen
angezeigt hat wer eigentlich da recht
wahr zu sein
durch diesen bündnis
ich finde die ja wenn ich das sagen darf
die europäer sind total blauäugig hier
denken das thema carbon geschäfte von
frankreich wegnehmen gar nicht die für
die australien haben jetzt wirklich
angst vor china und die wollen die beste
uwo meine jacke und aktiv für die
pflanzen ja aber die franzosen haben den
preis verdoppelt und nicht liefern
können und die franzosen können nur
diese boote liefen sie sind
in zehn jahren austria hat zunehmende
angst vor china china max sanktionen
gegen austria und die wurden die
bestmögliche u-boote und
es ist wirklich ein kalter krieg da in
asien es geht nicht um wirtschaft es
geht um strategie und unpolitische und
sicherheitsfragen nicht nur wirtschaft
es ist nicht so dass plötzlich hat ford
hat den dir weggenommen weggeschnappt
vom fuß oder so es geht um eine ganz
tolle u boote wurde die 23 monaten und
unter wasser bleiben können und diese
boote aus denen man ihre hunde die nur
ein paar wochen unter großem alliierten
geht man schon anders um und dann sagt
ja schon davor wenn man schon seit
mehreren jahren verhandelt
micron markt eine große geschichte
daraus verbauen wo der tour stehen
wahrscheinlich und das ist der aktuell
neunter botschaft oder schon so groß
natürlich ein einfaches argument weil er
natürlich gibt wahlkampf in frankreich
in sechs monaten aber trotzdem gibt es
ja gewisse arten wie man mit mit
alliierten zusammen das gar nicht sagen
das problem und die saison mal ganz
abrupte abzug ohne die alliierten zu
informieren also natürlich jetzt viele
fragen
der hat auch noch mal gezeigt wie gross
setzt sich die entfremdung ist zwischen
den usa und den europäischen alliierten
also einfach die koffer einzupacken und
zu sagen wir gehen ohne vorher zu
überlegen und so ist ist einem
ausrufezeichen und merkel bin ich noch
mal auf merkels rüttgers hat das schon
ganz früh gesagt hat schon vor ich
glaube in irgendein bierzelt gesagt wir
müssen autonomer werden die kleinstadt
ist unabhängiger werden völlig richtig
ja völlig richtig nur und beiden tramper
des ohnehin gezeigt aber beiden zeigt es
letztlich auch völlig legitim aus seiner
sicht dass die europäer sich
emanzipieren müssen und erwachsener
werden müssen hätte schon das zeigt doch
auch das unterstelle ich jetzt mal auch
eben nicht nur unter einem präsidenten
trump sondern auch unter beiden vor
allem eigene interessen im vordergrund
stehen und wenn das gut funktioniert mit
europa oder mit frankreich als pana
wunderbar aber man fühlt sich da nicht
verpflichtet also offensichtlich nimmt
man dann doch diesen partner nicht so
ernst dass man sagt ich weiss nicht
meine chance
dann vorher in my globig biden als vize
präsident wurde aufwärts pakistan das
war das hast du lesen und man wusste in
europa sei lohne hatte dass das mit von
frankreich in dieser u-boote nicht so
läuft wie gesprochen man kann hier
behaupten ja das ist alles
wirtschaftliche gründe aber ich glaube
dass wirklich nicht ich glaube
sicherheit gehen und stehen vorrangig
mainz geld weil es wird es wird kein die
franzosen wären nicht mengen an
arbeitsplätzen dadurch
aber es geht es geht eher um und im stil
und wie und im umgang mit partnern
eigentlich ja ok entschuldigung ich
[Gelächter]
mag keine große geschichte raus ich
glaube deutschland spielt eine gute
rolle deutschland wurde auch die u boote
da wir kaufen aber die deutsche u boote
könnten anscheinend nicht diesel und
nuklear die franzosen könnten auch event
von nuklearen das ist was die astral
wohnen probiere dass man europa zu
verstehen unter sicherheitsaspekten und
nicht nur wirtschaftliche und das ist
das problem mit deutschland und china
deutschland denkt zuviel wirtschaftliche
interessen merkels jedes jahr dahin
geflogen mit wirtschaftsvertreter und
die menschenrechte das ist der größte
handelspartner die in deutschland habe
ja und ich war erschrocken vor einem
jahr habe ich eine umfrage hier gelesen
das 333 muss der deutsche haben jetzt
eine positive
einstellung gegenüber
36 jährige gegenüber ok das zugegeben
dass wenn der job sei noch ein paar
jahre davor war das 80 prozent positiven
gegen die usa 0 15 china ist enorm an
popularität gewonnen hier in deutschland
der die leute sind eingeschlafen und
erkennen dass nicht das war eine gefahr
dass ist das esse ich sehe das ähnlich
diese gefahr dass china mit seinen
konfuzius instituten und so genannten
bildungseinrichtungen sich praktisch als
alternatives modell zu etablieren
versuchen das irrwitzig aus brüssel
perspektive dass die größten
brückenbauprojekte brückenbauprojekte
der eu von china realisiert werden dass
der firma wie strabag aus österreich
keine chance mertel staat
subventionierte chinesische unternehmen
eu steuergelder abgreifen und hier das
ganze realisieren und was ich mit großer
sorge sehe es in der tat die
abhängigkeit der deutschen wirtschaft
von china der meist verkaufte bmw der
welt der 5er in langen den sie hier in
berlin gar nicht kriegen ist das modell
in china und das ist der meistverkaufte
bmw viele deutsche autokonzerne
finanzieren den umschwung zur
elektromobilität mit dem absatz den sie
in china machen da erwirtschaften sie
das geld daimler baut sogar glaube ich
noch für klassische fossile und
das ist genau die frage wie kriegen wir
das hin dass ira so abhängig sind so
abhängig sind und trotzdem uns sozusagen
nicht kaufen lassen und da glaube ich
dass die nächste bundesregierung an der
ja nun die grünen beteiligt sind
akzentuierte auftreten werden als die
alte das wird auf jeden fall ein anderer
ton werden ob der was verändert in china
und das senioren hilft ist eine zweite
frage aber ich glaube dass dieses sehr
leise treten ein ende haben wir das wird
sicherlich auch ein stückchen bruch mit
der merkel tradition werden
das bewusstsein und viele diskussion
innerhalb der großen parteien in
deutschland also bei den beiden bei der
spd sowohl als bei der cdu und den
grünen sowieso aber bei den diesen
beiden partei ist es nicht so dass sie
dass sie einfach nur blauäugig in dem
inneren verhältnis zu china schauen wenn
man wenn man wenn schon hinter den
kulissen auf jeden fall aber man ist
vergleichsweise dezent wenn man sich
vorstellt dass die chinesen sanktionen
gegen eu parlamentarier verhängen ging
reinhard bütikofer der ja sehr engagiert
ist der grüne im eu-parlament in sachen
china den praktisch blocken nicht mehr
reinlassen da sieht man wie weit sie in
unsere politik so raytion versuchen
etwas aus eu-sicht wenn ich das mal
sagen wir dringend notwendig ist dass
wir bei ausschreibungen nicht hingehen
und chinesische staatskonzern einer
solchen digital diktatur
diese aufträge vermitteln mit
europäischem steuergeld sondern die das
public procurement die ausschreibung
müssen so gestaltet werden dass
chinesische staatskonzerne wo
zwangsarbeit zugehört wurde
staatsfinanzierung zu gehört sich nicht
mehr bewerben können es muss irgend ein
weg gefunden werden es kann nicht sein
dass man sagt das europäische
wettbewerbsrecht ist nicht für zuständig
also dürfen sie sich bewerben also
dürfen sie mit ihren
menschenrechtsverachtenden methoden auch
noch unsere steuergelder in der eu bei
projekten realisieren das ist grotesk
jetzt ist es natürlich so sie sprechen
es an was wird passieren wenn die grünen
mit drin sind aber wir sind in einer
situation wir haben ja die zahlen eben
gesehen wo wir wahrscheinlich eine sehr
lange zeit haben werden in der nicht
klar ist wer deutschland regiert und in
welcher koalition
das bedeutet übrigens für frankreich
dass es wieder direkt vor der wahl dann
ein solches vakuum geben wird und
frankreich wird lange warten müssen
russland wird ja warten müssen darauf
wer der neue ansprechpartner ist was
glauben sie was ist das dringendste was
da jetzt auch liegen bleibt wenn wir
sagen wir jetzt mal die nächsten drei
monate uns in deutschland damit
beschäftigen werden eine neue regierung
zu finden
was für ross und meinen sie was bleibt
liegen was die größten baustellen die so
dringend sind dass es schwierig ist dass
es hier keine regierung geben wird
erstmal also keine regierung wir haben
immer eine regierung aber keine neue
regierung gibt ich glaube ich glaube
jetzt ist tatsächlich situation so dass
zwei christen partei kräfte 2 christel
politischen kräften sind dann so sagen
wir zumindest den exit polls
entsprechend relativ gleichmäßig und
jeder partei oder partei union auch cdu
csu und spd sie wollen jetzt beide als
bei der politischen kräften dann die
regierung bilden ich glaube vor zwei
tagen vor 2017 war die situation
vollkommen anders weil da war relativ
klar wer dann diese diesen auftrag
bekommen hat und die frage war einfach
nur weh werden welche bedingungen dann
bei diesen koalitionsgespräche wer füllt
und wenn nicht und hier glaube ich beide
parteien werden versuchen die gespräche
zu führen und wer dann am besten mit wem
verhandelt das wird dann
die frage ist sieht russland dieses
vakuum was da jetzt erst mal entsteht
entspannt und sagt einfach wir warten
das ab wir haben es nicht eilig russland
sieht vor allem
kein großes problem oder wahrscheinlich
sogar kein riesengroßes unterschied
zwischen zwei figuren ihr jetzt von
laschet und herr scholz die dass das
problem oder die größte frage jetzt hier
russland ist wie viel
wie viele stimmen dann die grünen haben
werden und man lese dass angel annalena
baerbock nicht
in ostritz weil sowohl herr scholz wie
auch herr laschet sind ja keine
erklärten gegner von nord stream zweiter
sondern ja ganz zurückhaltend
formulieren insofern können kann
russland glaube ich aus der nord stream
zwei perspektive relativ relaxt sein
egal wer es wird die grünen sind nicht
so meter stark geworden die sind gegner
des projekts und scholz und laschet am
beide im grunde genommen in gewissem
sinne ihren frieden mit dem projekt
gemacht ja genau auf jeden fall und das
war auch die frage hört und das sind
dann berichterstattung die frage war so
von formuliert wie die grünen dann noch
diese beziehungen zwischen deutschland
und russland verschlechtern
das war unheimlich dass die grünen
angegriffen wurden sind aussagen dieser
fake news und so warum wollen die grünen
so ein ziel aus lust an wegen nur 20
oder
was hat muss dann gegen die grünen
zweistellig glaube ich glaube das sind
sie sprechen ihre diese diese news
kampagne
ich glaube
da sind vor allem zwei große themen oder
themenbereiche nord schon zwei und
grundsätzlich die beziehungen zwischen
deutschland und russland weil gewinnen
und treten eher dafür dass die
sanktionen täter verzehrt werden oder
zumindest so heißen bleiben und man geht
nicht auf diesen niemand hier in
deutschland so dass allofs einen
kuschelkurs so die grünen machen dass
nicht die grünen sind auch härter was
die ukraine betrifft also gegenüber
russland also das ist natürlich
verbunden
frankreich wird das sich am schwersten
tun wahrscheinlich damit dass es
womöglich jetzt wieder eine längere zeit
ein vakuum gibt oder naja also wie wir
schon besprochen habe es gibt ja bald
ganz bald in frankreich im april wird
gewählt im mai haben wir womöglich einen
neuen präsident oder präsidentin je
nachdem wie die machtverhältnisse
aussehen
vielleicht kommt noch gibt es noch eine
andere frau die kandidiert kann noch
kommen oder wie schnell man hier kommt
noch aber sie haben die
ratspräsidentschaft ist und die
festliche laufen
januar 22 22 gibt ist frankreich hat die
ratspräsidentschaft inne und da möchte
man natürlich manuell micron diese zeit
nutzen um noch einmal zu glänzen braucht
er die deutsch französische achse ja
natürlich weil sonst keiner kann da
keine keine keine reformen erreichen in
europa ich meine natürlich während
französische wahlen nicht durch die
europäische politik
entschieden aber das ist ja ein 1 1 1 1
t raum wo er sich wo er sich auf jeden
fall gut präsentieren kann auf dem
europäischen parkett das ist zumindest
das was er machen möchte
und jetzt weiß er nicht wann er an
ansprechpartner in berlin bekommen
glauben sie
emanuel makro wünscht sich eher armin
laschet oder olaf scholz ich glaube er
kann und er würde unterschiedliche sache
erreichen je nachdem er zwischen den
beiden bekommt also mit armin laschet
könnte ja sicher
gute kompromisse schließen was die
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
betrifft was den stabilitätspakt
betrifft als wir schon erwähnt haben
könnte schwieriger sein vom winde wir
ein
fdp-minister haben bei dem
finanzministerium in berlin und mit olaf
scholz könnte er wiederum glaube ich
bessere ergebnis erreichen bei über
dieser
haushaltsfragen und
auch ich glaube letztens hat er auch
sich sehr positiv geäußert über diesen
konzept von
strategische autonomie
worauf auch die franzosen sehr sehr
großen wert legen dass es stattfindet
sind frankreich ich habe mich schnell
bei jedem mann mit großer freude in
brüssel betrachtet der direkten
verhandlungen geleitet hat und diverse
clock is ticking gesagt hat und waren je
träumt ja auch davon französischer
präsident zu werden und er hat dies ein
interview gegeben das war auch freunde
klar deutsch französische achse super
tandem blablabla aber ich finde es
eigentlich auch ganz witzig wenn wir
immer breiter denken und gesagt wir
könnten doch auch mal zurück mit italien
enger zusammenarbeiten da kommt
natürlich jemand wie mario draghi ins
spiel der aus meiner sicht was die
autoritative ausstrahlung angeht ja
extrem stark dasteht als ehemaliger
ezb-chef whatever it takes und so weiter
und so weiter die italien nach vorne
bringt die wachstumsraten im italienisch
maschinenbau sind gigantisch die korona
bekämpfung die impfung läuft besser als
in deutschland italien steht plötzlich
für seine verhältnisse blenden da
regiert eine super autorität das heißt
für die franzosen öffnet sich ein neuer
partner natürlich lächelt oder scholz
nicht unwichtig aber draghi hat ein
format von dem beide glaube ich nur
träumen aber hier sehe das heißt bevor
wir dann übrigens auch immer wieder nach
amerika schauen müssen das bedeutet doch
dass
es nicht automatisch so zu sagen so ist
dass diese starke führung die unbenommen
angela merkel in europa hatte auch in
den beziehungen zu frankreich hatte es
ist nicht so als würde man einfach nur
warten da kommt jemand neues und diese
rolle ist automatisch für deutschland
vorgesehen sondern dieses vakuum könnte
auch von anderen ländern genutzt werden
zu sagen jetzt möchte ich der die starke
mann frau sein ja also merkel könnte
erst mal kommen könnte natürlich
versuchen so ein bisschen merkels rolle
für sich zu nehmen also sagen ihr die
krone zu übernehmen er wird feststellen
ohne sie als begleitung wird es für ihn
schwierig aber man kann sich nach neuen
partnern um gucken und ich glaube man
sollte mario draghi nicht unterschätzen
das ist jemand der auch in richtung
schuldenunion sympathien hat also da die
makro linie fährt die bruno lemaire
linie fährt sozusagen den club med
verstärkt zunächst italien spanien
portugal frankreich usw da tun sich also
neue potenzielle partner auf und sie
haben völlig recht es ist nicht gesagt
dass herr laschet oder erst jetzt
sozusagen der neue super partner werden
sondern vielleicht wird es wirklich so
eine dreiecksgeschichte auch die sich da
entwickelt herr kirschbaum den glauben
sie wünscht sich joe biden lieber ist es
eher olaf scholz oder er armin laschet
eine unionsgeführte regierung lieber
weil man da diesem nato 10 2% vielleicht
nicht
ganz kurz sagen ich merke perspektiv man
fragt sich warum haben die deutsche
diese stick mit dem schuldenbremse und
sowohl gebe die deutsche stimme mehr
geld aus oder also die ganze welt gibt
das geld aus moers die haben aber die
deutschen haben diese dieses schwarze
nullen in blut und das
frage antwort ja wen wen man beiden
möchte beiden ich war natürlich würde
ich sagen wir können mit jedem regierung
arbeiten und die märkische präsidenten
haben ganz gut immer gearbeitet könntest
du über tiefe regierungen in deutschland
die die waren wirklich immer das
transatlantische
wenig wenig probleme glaube ich aber
trotzdem ist olaf scholz vor beiden
irgendwie aus dem gleichen holz
geschnitten die sind beide mitte in
ihrer linke partei die haben progressive
flügel in ihrer parteien und ich sind
ständig mit diesem spannungen sie wollen
die parteien die mitte halten und ihre
partei gehe nichts ich kann mir
vorstellen mit ihm ein bier zusammen
trinken würden die können vergleichen
was das wie das ist mit progressive in
ihrer partei umzugehen insofern nicht
glaube einem amerikanischen präsident
kann mit beide mögliche kannst du hier
geht was ein bisschen problematisch ist
es die linke flügel der spd und diese
geräusche gegen nato gegen zwei prozent
was diese helm nütze nichts sagt ab und
so dass diese bundes in deutschland die
lust war versöhnlich diese amerikanische
kampfflugzeuge diese nukleare teilhabe
wurden die in frage stellen das macht
schon angst und auch die die geräusche
von der linke parteien nato auflösen da
da wird schon nicht über den vorteil ist
dass sie nicht so viel geschrieben haben
in ihrem programm über über verteidigung
verteidigung ja in dem spd-programm
insofern gibt es noch viele ja da wird
das wieder raus fdp und grünen eher
schwierig werden genau aber ich glaube
urlaub scholz ami laschet unterscheiden
sich da zumindest was diesem stärkung
der nato an geht nicht so sehr ich denke
eine mehrheit der deutschen ist dafür
dass diese transatlantische bundes
bleibt ich glaube viele viele spd-wähler
generell die wellen arg enttäuscht wenn
plötzlich die linke in dieser koalition
wären diese anti nato kräfte würden sich
ein bisschen verschaukelt fühlen denke
ich ich bin kein deutsche wähler aber
es ist wohl die amerikaner sondern viele
westdeutsche haben probleme aber was die
linken in landesregierung das überhaupt
kein problem ich höre dass oft hier in
berlin die linken sind weg die sind
praktisch kein thema mehr die geringen
um fünf prozent also dieses oder ohne
sohn roth von daher kann beiden ganz
tiefenentspannt seiner kranken auf die
finanz sein bruder aufmachen denn ich
meine armin laschet hat im liebesbriefe
geschrieben am in der stadt hat ja sogar
für seine verhältnisse mutig in der faz
einen artikel geschrieben
er sagt mensch angela merkel du musst
jetzt auch mal als kanzlerin auf das
liebeswerben von makro an der sorbonne
eingeben hat lassen artikel schrieben da
kommt ja gar keine antwort angela willst
nicht mehr antworten und umgekehrt olaf
scholz hat ja diesen corona wiederaufbau
von als blaupause mit geschnitzt also
insofern hat makro mit beiden im grunde
um gute ansprechpartner also da kann er
fast losen wenn er lieber müsste
russland sieht das ähnlich wenn ich sie
verstanden wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe die grünen werden
zumindest keine bundeskanzlerin stellen
und damit wird vladimir putin einfach
abwarten und schauen mit wem er
weiterspricht genauso war es auch heute
sie haben beobachtet und
gesagt dass man erst mal abwarten soll
ich weiß nicht warum aber auch nicht
fragt man die ganze zeit über seinen
möglichen rohdaten zumindest gefragt hat
über die mögliche rot rot grüne
koalition was glaube ich davor nicht
möglich war und jetzt auch nicht dass er
jetzt im moment sieht das so aus als
wäre das auch keinen fall möglich
angehen ausgeschlossen und diese
koalition zum beispiel oder diese
möglichkeit war überhaupt nicht
besprochen
russischen medien politik und
wenn wir dann weiter das gespräch
abwarten was wäre dann bevorzuge ich für
russland oder wäre dann bevorzugt als
kanzler ich glaube
gefühl mäßig natürlich spd und herr
scholz aber mit beiden kanzlerkandidaten
man sprechen können weil sie ganz
passend und sagen wir
verständlich für die russische von
männern geprägte politik sind und weil
sie auch schon über seine erfahrung
verfügen weil sie schon haben als organ
der spd minister gabriel der nordstream
2 auf den weg gebracht hat ja wirklich
kriege ich habe auch das gefühl die
wussten freuen sich auf das sind spd
kanzlerin db vorzogen ja und es gibt nur
gabriel es gibt natürlich gerhard
schröder
und auch ganz viele andere politiker in
spd
unterstützen dann diese diese
gesprächskanäle oder verhandlungen mit
russland
gefühlsmäßig mehr als die politiker von
cdu ich glaube dass du eine große
nervosität in brüssel ist das jetzt das
ellen lang dauert bis man sich einigt
und das bis tief in die französische
ratspräsidentschaft dauert das man
wirklich eine handlungsfähige regierung
hat das angela merkel als dauerbrenner
immer weiter auftaucht zu sagen als
geschäftsführer bundeskanzlerin das wäre
extrem super optimal weil die probleme
flüchtlingskrise haben wir noch gar
nicht darüber gesprochen schuldenkrise
stabilitätspakt ii sind ja das sind
alles da und da finde ich auch noch mal
ohne jetzt hier zum 3d fans wären aber
nicht mal so ein akzent spannend weil
wir hatten ja mit italien das problem
wir hatten ja die hilfsorganisation in
eine extrem schwierige situation
gebracht hat indem er sie versuchte zu
kriminalisieren dass die flüchtlinge im
mittelmeer gerettet haben indem er
millionenstrafen ihn verhängt hat das
ist alles weg vom tisch seitdem draghi
da ist also es ist wirklich ein anderer
geist was die rettung im mittelmeer
angeht natürlich ist trage niemand der
sein würde kommt her aber diese art
helfer zu kriminalisieren häfen zu
bloggen es ist jetzt so dass salvini
sich vor gericht verantworten muss den
unterlassener hilfeleistung und trage da
einen neuen akzent auch in der
flüchtlingspolitik setzt der vielleicht
auch noch mal eine initialzündung auf
der europäischen ebene sein könnte ich
muss sie leider
unterbrechen an dieser stelle wir sind
nämlich leider schon am ende ich würde
sie ganz kurz bitten als allerletzte
runde wirklich nur im idealfall nur ja
nein einmal von ihnen ihre meinung hören
glauben sie dass diese führungsrolle die
deutschland in der welt dann doch hatte
nach angela merkel weiter möglich ist ja
absolut es muss weiter möglich sein ich
hoffe dass hier wirklich wird in europa
ja aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass
andere akteure stärker werden frau
sommer ja ich glaube ja aber es könnte
auch vorstellbar seien das ja andere
akteure stärker werden vor allem wenn
ich deine frau carla anschauen
wo allerdings waren sind das müssen wir
alles abwarten ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für diese spannende runde hier
an diesem abend das war schon unser
erster internationaler spät shoppen an
dieser stelle ich danke ihnen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer auch für
interesse